[Music]
hey what's up it's our one year
anniversary special show we go through
five of the top calls of all time
we replay them we talk about what i did
good what i could do better next time
what's going on in the hearts and minds
of listeners and we tell you what's to
come stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
yo yo
what up this is john with the dr john
delony show so glad you're with us
there's like a billion podcasts and you
somehow you picked this one so we're so
glad you're here and you're with us
james
kelly nikki b sarah everybody
this is the big one guys
it's a big day you like how i did that
this isn't that big
it is a big deal trust me from our
perspective this is a big deal
after all of the meetings that we're
like uh we think this is gonna tank this
is the one year anniversary show
on the big
delaney show woo-hoo
first ladies and gentlemen still
employed this is such a big deal first
episode came out on august 31st
2020
man and i haven't killed you yet
i'm look at that i'm gonna disagree with
that i mean this is john 3.0 i disagree
hey so look at that
hey um i don't know how you can turn the
thing that way the the cameras
everybody out there this is part of the
the delony squad the gang who helps
everything stay together
and i like
jeremy over there is acting like hey i'm
one of the gang guys i'm in he's super
not he's uh
there you go he's out of here will and
even don and john everybody rachel and
rachel cory everyone brad natalie and
berlia it's so good meg alicia everybody
andy
that's only like half of the crew
i knew that you would just wing it so i
actually wrote down the names just so we
could cody and corey and eva and brad
natalie brillia rachel john will shelby
connor trevor mckenzie alicia zach and
zach and sarah and nick and ben and
catherine in brooklyn
we still talking about brooklyn even
though she
all right half these people i think you
drove out of the company but we'll still
thank them
that's actually a fair statement they
they're like oh we see the trajectory of
our lives and we're out right brooklyn
we miss you if you're listening to this
same with you catherine and rachel and
dawn and amy and jeremy and blake and
everybody blake
the godfather
dude
good to see you man
hey listen everybody i'm so grateful um
there's zero percent chance that we
thought this would still be happening a
year after we started this thing zero
and none of this i was gonna say
to the listening audience who's like man
that guy's really smart
they don't think that ever and
none of this happens without you guys
i'm so grateful thanks to everybody
high five congratulations to all the
guys for randomly wearing blue that just
seems weird
oh gosh dude cody cody's wearing blue
and he brings a cake in how do i get the
camera to see this
it's right there i don't want to tilt it
can you see we got john a les paul oh
less fall cake man you have to eat it on
air i'm gonna eat it on air this is the
first sugar i've had like in six months
i appreciate it
well come in here come wave this is cody
cody runs my entire life he's everything
and he wears blue shirts and he we wear
the same clothes good to see you man
congrats dude
i fought for a telly cake but who made
this it smells good uh lauren at our
company lauren piper made that
ah it's a gibson cake this is so great
well hey everybody cheers with your
coffees and your high fives and whatever
thank you all so much for being around
we made it a year
all right so here's the here's the
data's ready
oh man i got cake on my arm now
i'm gonna move this over here this is
not gonna end well
oh
that's oh man
it smells so good in here oh my
that's sugar-free right
oh yeah it's all stevia
you don't it's know what that means
that's so great
all right so we're one year in
we've got
10 million views on the youtubes
i've learned i had a youtube channel a
few weeks ago that's pretty exciting
75 000 subscribers is that good
yeah everyone i look at has like 11
million
i'm gonna go with good it's funny i'll
get there
and in the podcast you get five million
downloads that's kind of a big deal huh
is it i don't know i feel like people
are going to google and be like dude me
and my brother have a
show about cats in our basement it's got
five minutes i don't know what that's
good that sounds great it is good i have
i always say okay we have 17 listeners i
have five friends and i don't have five
million and my mom can't even hit
refresh so that tells me it's good
so hey what's your favorite part of the
show been so far kelly
let me put this way what's what's your
favorite part about entering this new
world honestly it's been because you
know james and i do the ramsay show as
well and we started that
it was already a huge show it was
already up and running and then we kind
of took over and just basically tried
not to sink the ship
which we've done pretty well and but
this was fun to build from the ground up
it was completely different than
anything i'd ever done
um starting it building it figuring out
what it was going to be like so that has
been the most fun for me
jimmy yeah none of us knew what we were
doing this type of show we we like kelly
said we've done like a collar driven
show but not one that's
not live and that has to be produced and
stuff like that so we were all we're all
new at this and it's been awesome to
figure it out as we go together
and we got blake back there we got nick
who's been running the cameras for a
couple months now man
nick we're glad you're here sarah are
you still back there yes who cuts and
pays all this so great man what a rad
crew this is awesome okay so today's
show we're gonna go through we've picked
our favorites right the top five of all
time
um and we're gonna go through them the
ones who have
ended up becoming the best clips ever i
guess is that how you say that i think
the best clips ever just the ones that
we remember that we liked
yeah so we got connor our youtube guy
and eric our podcast guy in terms of who
deal with the distribution to send us
the most popular episodes on youtube and
on podcasts and then we kind of picked
out our favorite five we sort of each
picked one or two
from those and they they're they're the
most popular so they're the ones that
got the most views or the most downloads
and so we're gonna
kind of show them and then talk about
them afterwards so you're you're up we
watched these last night
there's like a trip down sadness lane
man a some of these were in the old
studio i was not good how we have i i'm
not great now there was some roughness
back then they weren't great hey they're
the top performing episodes for a
reason i don't know what that reason is
you know what the reason is that's right
okay so you want to introduce the first
one
uh you can do it you're up first all
right the first one the the one that is
spun up on us is i'm living in a sexless
marriage what should i do it it was
episode 17 and it aired on october 7th
2020
man that was right in the middle of the
the world chaos living
sexless marriage what should i do
i live in a sexist marriage uh for over
nine years and i don't know what to do
um
i'm
i've gained weight i'm a little
depressed i i don't know what to do
so sexless marriage up it's been suckles
for nine years or y'all been married for
nine years and it's evolved into this
we
we've been there for nine years and
since we got married it's
his libido or his desire has decreased
he has been tested his testosterone is
low
then we just recently tested and it's
high now it's normal but his desire
isn't there
okay and it's hard for a woman to have
um
a higher desire or i guess
maybe i don't know if i'm the only woman
that has this in america
but
my husband has like zero desires we have
intimacy once every two months once
every month once every three months it's
very difficult yeah so
you posed several questions there so
number one no actually it's it's a big
secret and it's a secret that weighs on
the hearts of women millions of women
across the country it weighs in the
hearts and backs of millions of men
across the country is this idea of
expected libido
guys are
the the cultural narrative is that guys
are just these sex crave lunatics that
are always wanting to do it and that's
all they ever think about and
wives are prepped for this well you know
he's just gonna and then they get to
this marriage with a set of
mixed-matched expectations
and then things just go awry
so out of just sheer curiosity
what are the things you've tried over
the last nine years
well um
i've tried role playing
i've bought very sexy lingerie
even though i'm not into porn and he was
very important when we were dating and
then suddenly it just he
took off all the porn out of that out of
the house when we were dating our sex
life was awesome
when we were dating and then i've even
suggested if you want if that stimulates
you if you want to watch porn we can try
what they're doing and
it just
i don't know we've even tried to
set up a schedule
you know to see if
you know such days we can role play and
you know we'll meet me at a bar we'll go
to a hotel
nothing and so yeah you've gotten to the
point where you're trying to force feed
it in there um what yeah or just you've
gotten to a point where you're trying to
make it happen what does he say
he's very ashamed and
late we had a huge fight um
a couple days ago
i'm sorry i'm getting emotional no of
course
he just said that i have to deal with it
and it's
difficult yeah absolutely
we've i've you know we're
we've been trying to have a baby but
like i told him we need to try
if we're trying to have a baby we
haven't been able to conceive in five
years but
we both need to
do our part
right so i i just feel lost i feel very
lonely yeah i feel very alone abandoned
emotionally i've never ever cheated on
my husband i've never wanted to do that
and i don't want to do that ever
i'm a christian woman i love my husband
i don't know what to do then i
sank into a little bit of depression i
feel i gained 20 pounds because of it
i don't know what to do
so number one i want to applaud you for
reaching out and being vulnerable okay
thank you thank you for honoring me with
your trust there okay thank you the
second thing is is trite as this sounds
this is more than likely not a valentina
issue
okay
and i want you to
i mean i praised you for giving it all
you had
and for really trying to work through if
it was situational based if it was
desire based if it was
i'll do
fantasy based whatever it happens to be
it sounds like you've put in the effort
and the love and the care and you've
tried to really do your part there and i
i salute you okay i want you to hear
that
um
the other side of you just got to deal
with it that's not an acceptable answer
to me and so where this is clear this
call is hard for me is i can't talk to
him
right and so my guess is
well i don't even want to to speculate
there's so much that leads to low
libido there is so much that leads to
um the potential for sexless marriages
and it can be everything from
like you said shame that's all it's
relational based all the way back from
childhood there could be this moment
when you became girlfriend you became
wife and he's got a picture of wife
which is really just an elevated mother
and guys don't like to sleep with their
mothers and so it could be this big
psychological quagmire it could be
something not testosterone related but
something
other
more medically biological related it
could be that he is finding himself
attracted to
men and not women it could be a hundred
thousand different things and we've
discussed that you know are you
homosexual do you like men
um he says no he's not attracted to men
um he's not an uh sex uh
a drug addict at all right he's not into
drugs he's not cheating i've looked
and nothing is just
but so here's the deal here's the deal
listen listen
listen
this is gonna be hard to hear but he is
not a
puzzle to be solved
okay and he's not a problem to be fixed
he's a person to be with and what i'm
guessing is the amount of shame he is
walking through the world right now is
extraordinary
and people who are feeling shame think
of a backpack full of cinder blocks
and people who are carrying that around
say things that they don't mean
they get frustrated at the world just
because their knees hurt just taking
simple steps
and so statements like you just got to
deal with it that's not a statement of
somebody who loves and cares and desires
somebody that's a statement of somebody
who's hurting okay
yeah and he's had an erection problem so
he has ed right he does have that but
and
of so much of that can be psychological
and physical and trauma it can be so
much have you guys gone to see a
counselor has he going to see somebody
psychologically
we have um the first year of the
marriage because
from the day that we got married we had
intimacy that day and then five months
later
we did it and i kept you know
um pursuing him and nothing so i did go
to a counselor by myself at first he did
go for one or two sessions but then he
didn't want to he was too ashamed to
talk there you go to a woman
about the situation about the fact that
he can't get an erection and it's
difficult for men than for women that's
what he says well that's just again it's
not that's just guys him trying to
package this in a way that he can wake
up every morning because the the the
shame is pretty overwhelming
um okay so he's got to this is not a you
know i think so this is a have to
he has to go see somebody and talk about
the things that are
wound up in his heart and soul
and here's the thing you can't make him
do that
the more you try to control and pressure
and push that's more bricks and more
rocks of shame and the backpack that
he's already fallen over from right
what you can do is you can go see
somebody
to deal with your frustration and your
heartache
and you can model for him what
somebody's standing a little bit taller
and a little bit taller and a little bit
taller looks like okay okay
i want to i'm telling you this but i'm
also telling anybody watching this
anybody listening to this
life is too short to live
in a sexless marriage life is too short
to live with
bad sex with people who don't talk to
one another people who don't communicate
people put up for a decade with things
that they don't like they're not
comfortable with things that they wish
their partner was doing just because
they they carry these secrets around
they don't have hard conversations with
one another and so we will go two years
five years 10 years 20 years without
having hard conversations and and
suddenly man we find ourselves
sitting on a couch again two inches
apart from one another and 2 000 miles
away
we're on different planets right
and life is too short for that i'm
speaking in the choir here i know that
the only person that's gonna be hard to
hear the only person valentina that you
can deal with right now the only person
that you can
you can
you can change is you
you can control your thoughts and your
actions
and the things that he says the things
that he doesn't respond to a decade
of trying to become his muse
is warning your soul out it's heavy and
it's exhausting
and
i want you to walk with a professional
counselor for a season
to make sure that that doesn't become
your shame that you're carrying that
somehow your value is diminished because
you couldn't accomplish this thing in
somebody else
you have more value than that you've got
more integrity than that
and you are worth more than that
and i want you to model for him what
getting well looks like what being whole
looks like i'm not concerned the fact
that he's got libido issues that happens
i'm concerned that he doesn't care
enough about you to go to the ends of
the earth to try to be whole and well
in men listening to this men watching
this there is not an excuse to not be
honest with a doctor
there is not an excuse to not go see a
counselor and say help me
i am drowning the person that i love
more than anything else in the world
because of crap that i'm carrying that
happened to me when i was a kid there's
no shame in not being able to put down
your own bricks guys
i'm telling you from a dude that
struggled with it it's hard it is hard
but when we commit to somebody for the
rest of their life and we tell them that
we love them we have an obligation to go
to the ends of the earth
the ends of the earth that means going
to have an awkward check at the doctor
that means sitting down with a therapist
male or female i don't care
and saying here's what happened to me
when i was a kid
here's what i see when i look in the
mirror here's
what
a wife
meant to me growing up
and all of a sudden i can't be i was
wildly in love passionately in love
while dating
recklessly erotic when we were dating
and now that we're married it's i lost
it
um the whole world transmission the
whole thing changed i'm terrified of
being a dad whatever the thing is
the combination of medical psychological
guys go see somebody
and this is not just about sex this is
about
depression this is about anxiety this is
about guys who are
worried about being good parents i don't
care what your issue is guys get over it
the world needs us to step up and start
feeling the world needs us to step up
and start being vulnerable
the world needs us to step up and start
being with people not over them
connected to them not in charge of them
and so i'm i'm i'm
i'm begging you guys
go talk to somebody
that will hear you and that will love
you
all right that was it hey cheer
everybody sexless marriage right
we're gonna make this as awkward as
possible for everyone involved listeners
viewers everybody
uh all right so i'm living in a sexless
marriage what should i do what do you
think james
man this was um
she was really really sad
it was she's very vulnerable to call in
and
i think this was so early on this is
only october it's a couple months in
and for people to build
trust with you that quickly to where
they would call and ask your advice
about something this sensitive is pretty
amazing yeah she she was heartbroken and
i
that's when i knew early on that people
needed a place because i remember the
first few shows i don't even know if
these aired but there's the first few
shows when i would ask somebody like why
are you calling me on the radio and
their answer was indicting
it just answering i got nobody i got
nobody i can tell this stuff to and you
could hear the pain in this woman's
voice kelly what'd you think
we got um so i'm the one that i go
through all the emails and
we got so much feedback off that one and
it made me
realize what an issue this is in
marriages because we had so many people
that say i'm exactly the same place what
do i do men and women both
um i would say primarily women that
emailed in but we got so much response
that it just made me sad that this is a
real legit thing
in marriages right now what i would what
is strange and again this is the nature
of my marriage versus others
how we've gotten to a place culture
where we can create kids together we
build homes together and
yet we cannot have this conversation in
our homes right and it's it's such a
barometer of where the status of our
relationship is what's our sex life like
and to hear this woman
the pain she was experiencing 10 years
she had taken
this as rejection and then had tried to
solve for rejection for so long on an
issue that it
it's clear to me it was not hers right
and then i think the deeper level
beneath the sex on this call was our
lack of
was that she was all in times 10 and he
wasn't and her shame and guilt drove her
to try to solve this problem and his tol
drove him to
neutral right
and
i just think she deserved better than
that and i know he deserved it like man
it was just a mess and i i my heart's
out for folks like this
um
i think that the hard part when you're
when you love somebody and you're trying
to do everything that works you try one
thing you try another thing and suddenly
you find yourself out way out on a limb
trying way out there and you lose
perspective of the whole the whole
relationship i don't know what do you
think i could have done differently on
this call
i don't know what you could have done
differently but i know this was a cool
example early on of how
sometimes you go into call and you think
it's black and white like this person's
wrong this person is right and you you
often will take a call that seems that
way and you'll say
hey i'm proud of you for trying all this
stuff but also
he's not the way he said he's not a
problem to be solved he's not a puzzle
he's not a problem to be fixed and
showing that like in almost every
situation there's there's responsibility
on both sides
and things that both people could be
doing differently and so it's like
your show is very much of both and show
and this was a good example of that so
it was cool how you said he's dealing
with a lot of shame
and
the more that you
try to fix him the more he's going to
kind of back off and
yeah we live in a i think we live in a
culture that has we try to fix people
try to fix up find a problem and fix it
instead of healing healing takes time
and it's gradual and scars remain but
sometimes bones grow back strong right
so there's all kinds it's changing the
metaphor i think
um and then yeah getting back to that
both and that's maybe been the the
greatest lesson for me over the last
year is
this guy's hurting really bad and he has
a responsibility to go get better right
she has done everything she can to try
to stay in this relationship
and she deserves more than what she's
than than where she's landed right so
it's both and and i think leaving both
and in we just live in a culture that
says it's either this or either that
and i think it's it's both in kelly
anything else where we go the next one
no i just thought that um one thing i
liked a lot you talked about already is
that
there's obviously something going on
with him and he's probably embarrassed
i know he is yeah and if it's a physical
issue that's hard to talk about but then
she's taking it as in maybe i'm not
attractive
um and so they're like living on these
two islands
and they probably both want the exact
same thing
you know i don't think he wants to live
this way either but they're both on
these islands and they just have to
figure out how to how to connect on it
but it is it's a hard thing to talk
about but we can talk about a million
other things in marriage
you know but i think we also get so
transactional once there's kids involved
in time and a house and it's easy to let
that fall to the wayside and then it's
hard to get back to it yeah i think
somebody who i say this too often on the
show i need to come up with some
different things but somebody's got
sometimes got to flip the lights on and
say
dude our sex life's a mess and we need
to talk about it and or
i i'm at a place now where i want
something different i want something
more or i want something
um unique or i want something weird or i
want something that i never thought i
wanted until now you just got to have a
relationship where you can have those
conversations and then for god's sake
when you go to the doctor go to a
counselor tell the truth right
guys are the worst about lying at the
doctor's office i'm a good man or with
their counselors
if you're going to pay a professional
it's like bringing a roofer over your
house and not telling them about the
leak in the back right like i don't want
to tell them so we're just gonna be
quiet now if you go to professional man
tell the truth and get the help you need
so you can move on i know there's shame
and embarrassment man we gotta get over
that stuff
[Music]
hey what's up i want to take a quick
break to talk about the most important
question i'm asked almost every day how
do i find a counselor if you can't find
a counselor in your area or you can't
afford one i've got a solution for you
i've partnered with a better help for
customized online therapy video chat
text chat phone counseling it's a
licensed therapist whenever and wherever
you need them go to betterhelp.com
deloney for 10 off your first month it's
cheaper and it's available all the time
this is for you your family and for
everyone else that's coming your way
take care of your mental health go to
betterhelp.com today
all right james what's the next one
uh kelly has the next one
uh i chose the one i'm seeing a married
woman and i feel guilty
and that was episode 135
just recently back on the 12th of july
i'm sure you remember the one i'm
talking about i do remember the one
you're talking about
the reason i i hate to say the word
liked this one but the reason i chose
this one is this was one of the first
times we had see you get we've seen you
get really direct with someone
whereas before it's always been
oh that's bad i'm so sorry blah blah
blah and this one you were like dude
you're alone yeah and but it's what was
necessary for this
and it's what he needed to see and that
really struck me because it it um was
just something different and we've seen
more of that now but sometimes
things require that yeah yeah everything
can't be you know handled with kid
gloves i it was about three months ago
or four months ago i realized i think i
was doing a disservice to people by not
getting to the point faster as a plus is
boring to listen to just me yammering
but also
man we gotta get to the point and get
there quick all right so here we go i'm
seeing a married woman
dot dot dot and i feel guilty
i'm calling you today because i am the
other man
and i'm
struggling on what to do and how to
progress forward here
um what is the other backstory here but
i don't know how much time i have to
really tell you everything going on up
to this point
so cut right to the decisions i've made
cut right to the chase so you made bad
decisions and you're the quote-unquote
other guy i'm pretty sure i know what
that means um
yeah she's been married
uh she was married for about a year we
you know first started out as friends
turned into relationship
now it's about you know nine months or
night four months ago uh after nine
months of being in a relationship she's
trying to know she's pregnant
um with your she's pregnant
uh
i doubt it's mine it's like very low
chance it's mine
um timing doesn't make any sense but at
the same time there's a possibility
and the guy the husband
still doesn't know about me
god doesn't know about anything that's
going on um
so why why you calling me man
i feel like my moral accomplice has
always
been wrong for so long that i'm trying
to debate about
how i step out of this and do i tell him
do i confront him
um
i just feel like my moral compass i mean
making the wrong choice after wrong
choice how do i make it right
i'll ask you man how do you make it
right
i mean it's like i i have feelings for
her i love her and
i'm struggling on how to progress and
either phase out of this because i love
her because i know it'll be best for a
family to be together hey how does this
end man
how does this end
that her husband and you and her go to
go to dinner one night and he's like you
know what we're married
but y'all y'all are more perfect than us
and so
my brother joshua
i i
am handing this one off to you i wish
all the best
is that how that ends
that's probably not how it's gonna end
yeah zero percent chance dude that won't
happen that way it only ends in ashes in
a disaster
and let's say she calls this her husband
and breaks it off and you all get
together
for the rest of your relationship every
time she takes a call you're gonna be
wondering if there's another another guy
every time she gets an email and closes
her laptop as you walk in the room
you're gonna wonder i wonder if there's
another another guy
there's no way this ends right
and by the way you don't love her
she is a safe
uh person to get into a relationship
with
because she's anchored in and you can
just trapeze off the side of this thing
with all all the fun and excitement and
joy and you have no responsibility at
all
none
well i mean i'm trying to do the
responsible thing which is i mean even
if it is my kid i mean i wanna raise you
i want to be with her and
i mean it's just listen to stepping out
joshua the responsible thing is to walk
away
if this happens
if this happens to be your kid which you
told me earlier it wasn't
if this happens to be your kid
then yes this whole thing got real real
real messy
right
and you may have a single woman to start
dating because if um
her husband's a person a character he's
probably gonna high five her and be gone
yeah cause she's having a baby by
somebody else
and god no you have don't go why would
you are you friends with her husband
no i'm not friends i've met him a few
times yeah
there's no reason to call him
i just feel like i've done so much
damage you know after a walk away
walk away
you're like a surgeon who is taking
somebody's organ out and they realize
they cut the wrong organ and they
realize oh gosh i've caused a lot of
damage i think the best thing to do here
is to keep cutting out other organs
and just keep cutting and keep cutting
and keep cutting
at some point the smart thing for that
doctor to do is to stop
put the scalpel down
yeah and you know you know this
why did it take a phone call to a
stranger
you know this man
because it's hard to hear it's hard to
walk you know i've
had i've struggled with uh finding
somebody you know that matches me and
it's just i'm tired of being alone
you're still completely alone man
that's the farce of this
you're totally completely alone
you are somebody else's chew toy on the
weekends
you are somebody else's excitement
you're a video game for somebody else
but they have their stable locked in
thing
you're completely alone joshua
and that's what breaks my heart for her
it breaks my heart for you
yeah
you know what i'm saying you're not on a
team right now
no
no you're right you're right and you're
worth more than that
she's worth more than that her husband's
worth more than that this baby coming
into the world's worth more than that
so true
you know what i mean am i crazy i know
no no you're not crazy you're not crazy
i mean bro you're
you're totally alone right now
it's hard to accept it's hard trust me i
know it sucks it's awful it's hard
but i'm not gonna lie to you do you have
friends that know this is going on do
you have like some guy buddies that you
sat down and talked to about this
well i have got buddies but the problem
is i haven't told him about it because
i'm ashamed yeah my shame has kept me
you know kept them in the dark and kept
me from saying the truth
will they hold you accountable
yeah
so
here's the thing man you can do what you
want
i'm gonna tell you right now i've been
around the block long enough to know
this thing ends
disaster
whatever fantasy you've come up with in
your head is not real
okay
so if i'm you
i would probably talk to call my buddies
over tonight
and say we gotta have a talk
just so i'd have somebody with me when i
go ahead and make that other phone call
because you're not gonna see her again
you can make that phone call says i'm
doubt i'm done
if this baby when it's born is mine then
i will step back in
but until then
i'm gonna do the thing of uh the right
thing i haven't been a virtuous person
i've been a person without character
i've been sleeping with a married woman
i've been violating somebody else's
marriage i'm out
walk away
that's it man
or dude
rock on
no no you're right you're right i just
need to
actually hear from somebody that i
respected of amount of characters so
it's just
it's hard for me to confess it to
somebody i know
i got that i got that hey that's that's
the first step here and that's what i'm
gonna tell you you need to do with your
guy buddies so they'll be there with you
and if your guy buddies are like my guy
buddies it's probably gonna get physical
yeah they're gonna wrangle me they
should that's what you're that's what
that's what made a character do for one
another that's what men and women of
character do for one another man
yes you called and you asked
um
the right thing is this is over before
the day's over
and you got some guys in your life that
are walking alongside you
and not the ex i get that you're tired
of being alone there's a right way and a
wrong way to do that that's like saying
i'm tired of being broke i can go rob a
store
or i can start taking community college
classes and get three jobs
one of those are going to result in
money at the end of the day one of those
is noble one of them is not
i don't know how to come back in from
these do we go
like what do you say like that was it
wow what do you think james hold on what
do you think
dating a married woman and i feel guilty
half of y'all cheered and corey was like
boo
yeah i mean kelly's right uh
especially earlier on in the in our
shows there would be some calls where it
was kind of like you're kind of
you're kind of circling the plane you're
not really you're trying to be a little
bit too nice to the person and it was
kind of like take a cue from dave and he
has nine minutes to answer this call and
he sometimes gets right to the core yeah
and this was one where we're back here
like cheering for you because
you didn't you didn't sugarcoat it for
this guy you're just like hey man
you're worried about being alone you are
alone yeah and
i find that getting out of a fantasy out
of a myth
is
it's hard to gently walk out of a
fantasy sometimes you gotta just shake
that cage and just say hey this is not
what you think this is
um
i don't know
that
did the guy ever write back in
i asked him to call back in i know
people call in a lot but yeah no i never
got anything back from him he's one i
want to follow up with someday and see
if he actually broke this thing off or
he's still living in la la land my
favorite thing that you said the one
that really struck me was when you said
how do you think this is going to go do
you think that y'all are going to go to
dinner with her and her husband and he's
going to be like it was a fun run but
obviously you two are better together
you y'all should just run off that was
just so kind of a
180 and it was like
yeah how do you think this is going to
end right that was my favorite part of
the whole whole call because i think
that's when he was like oh crud well and
i know it happens um but that's always
the
you know somebody is thinking about
leaving their spouse for somebody else
and
like how does that conversation actually
go like you think you know what i've
been married for a few years
we were wrong she's way better and
everybody high-fives each other and like
you're right let's hug it out and
go ahead and take the couch too because
it's good and i'll see the dog on the
weekend like just getting to how is this
actually gonna roll out right
i loved your surgeon analogy where
you're like you know if a surgeon messes
up he doesn't keep cutting and just
hopes that it works out he's like you
gotta stop you stop yeah yeah even
that's the the non-malfeasance right the
i don't know what we're doing now
intervention-wise but let's stop doing
this right that's become a slogan for me
in my personal life which is do
something different if you're living in
a way like i just can't just do
something different i don't care what it
is because that's not working right if
you're yelling at your kids if you
are ignoring your spouse whatever if
that's not working just do something
just try remember opposite george on
seinfeld and it just worked out great
great when he just started i'm gonna do
everything opposite of my instincts and
it went well for a while i feel like
that sometimes just gotta do something
different
um i'm looking at the political
landscape and we just think you know
what we've been yelling at each other
for about 18 months now what we probably
should do is just keep yelling and just
like that's not working so what if we
all said i don't know what if we hugged
let's just try hugging it can't be worse
maybe it could be worse but i don't
think it could be worse than it is now
or
you know who else is stupid what if we
just quit doing that because it's not
working anyway i don't know the other
interesting thing is that he
he was basically calling to
he hadn't told any of his friends he was
calling to sort of confess it to
somebody he's not confessing he didn't
know personally but that he respected
and thought high character
i started
i started looking through the youtube
comments on all these which was a huge
mistake you never do that one of them is
like this is basically like the
protestants version of confession like
calling into a show
but there is something to that like he
had to get it off his chest and yeah
yeah we should follow up i hope that he
did end it and walk away but he didn't
but all right so what's next man all
right next is a doozy my girlfriend has
gained weight what should i do
why did you pick that one james because
this was one that that pretty quickly
turned around
whenever we whenever we get these in
kelly lines them up ahead of time but we
only have like a
a little premise to go off of and so i
remember when this one came in
it quickly circular circulated around
the team and we had a little bit of an
audience in the control room to see
how it was going to go
and it kind of turned out a little bit
differently than we thought so we'll
we'll watch it and then talk about it
cool
right here uh my girlfriend has gained
weight
what should i do
so my girlfriend and i have been dating
for about a year
um and in the beginning of our
relationship we gained some happy weight
and over the past few months we've been
what is happy weight
just going out to eat and
cooking at home and just experiencing
life during covet and stuff like that
eating probably more than we should okay
um not working out okay and
steven i'm just gonna tell you right now
i feel like you are setting me up oh man
i have a feeling i know where this is
going man and you're already giving me
hives but go ahead
um and so we've been
working out for the past few months and
with how serious we're getting in the
stuff i have planned in the near future
the issue of our weight keeps coming up
in our conversations and it's really
kind of
pushing back the plans that we have
because it's creating a strain
and i'm trying to figure out if you
could help me out figure out a way to
approach it
uh in a better way
so we can grow a relationship and get
over this hurdle
oh stephen you are being very diplomatic
in your use of pronouns my man
you are saying our and we
i need you just to cut to the chase man
and i'm flinching for what i think
you're about to tell me but go for it
so
i've gained about 25 pounds and i ended
up losing 10 pounds from where i started
at so i started at 220 and i'm down
about 210 205.
after going up to 240
yes sir okay
and she has gained about 40 pounds and
is
continually
doing her best to work out but
unfortunately it's not really helping
out
stephen
are you calling me to ask
how you can tell your girlfriend
that she's gained weight
no we've we've had conversations and to
the point to where she
wasn't able to afford a gym membership
and she begged me to get one and i got
her the one that she wanted
um and for the past five months she's
gone nine times
and it's a hundred now it's 135 dollars
a month
and we even changed lifestyles like i
started grilling out took all the junk
food out i stopped drinking alcohol
because she said that's one thing she
wanted to do so i was like you know if i
want to make this happen and we want to
make this happen she wants to make this
happen i have to set an example
of what you know needs to change and
unfortunately
we're having a hard time understanding
each other in this moment of what we
need to do
to move forward and begin to
get to the process of where we want to
be with our physical appearance
oh man steven there's so much here
and
you know that we live in a cancel
culture right if i say the one wrong
thing here i'm done forever you realize
that right
i know and i don't want that to happen
you've just put a ball on a tee for me
and i'm also trying to be nice to you
because i kind of want to set you on
fire right now but that would be rude
and i'd go to jail okay so here's the
thing
i want to
just kind of cut through all of it
okay you've got to let the fantasy go
you are dating somebody
who does not share the same values as
you
you are dating somebody
who
is speaking the words that you want to
hear
but is making decisions for any number
of reasons
to live how she wants to live which is
different than a value you share
and for some reason you don't want to
see this
that she's not a math problem
and suddenly you're becoming her dad
by fixing her diet and even the way you
just said a month tells me you got some
rage underneath there brother
yeah i mean it's kind of i have a
personal experience with this because in
higher late high school or the college i
actually got up to 280 pounds i know but
here's the thing here's the thing
for you it was a
disciplined decision and a moral
decision and a character issue
and you're assigning your character and
you're assigning your discipline
to somebody else
who is not seeing it that way
in no amount of
mail
assignment
to
a young woman is gonna she's not gonna
go oh that's the thing
that's what i ah that's it
thanks man
i gained 40 or 50 pounds because i just
didn't know about x
and
you changed all of my food and you
bought me a real expensive thing and you
got angry and you sent me great
discipline and pinterest quotes and you
told me about your journey of weight
loss you lost 70 pounds which is really
impressive by the way
thank you that's what i was missing
thanks man
dude that's not how it's not gonna
happen
so how do i change my
my view set on this to
i guess stephen you leave stop hindering
steven you're getting all of the signals
you need
okay
that's tough it's real tough
because
uh just a few weeks ago i talked to her
parents about some stuff yeah of course
now i might have made an investment
yeah you're in it brother
oh that's tough it is
do you want to leave her
no she's honest her character is above
approach everything you want okay
stephen okay stephen
will you love her
50 pounds heavier than you have her and
a picture in your mind
yes
will you try to be a person who
co-creates a future with her and who
supports her and loves her and doesn't
try to father her
yes
then she's the one for you
and i guess i need to get over that
superficial mindset
hey hold on it's not about that it's not
about that because it's not bad to say
hey
who you were when we dated was 50 pounds
less if i showed up 50 pounds more to my
wife right now
that would be a thing and anyone who
says different than that is not telling
the truth
but
at 10 pounds at 20 pounds my wife would
come and sit down and say hey you're not
whole right now are you doing okay
not hey we should have more fish and
chicken
right yeah
and
she would know me well enough to know
that when i said something like i just
need to get some more kettle bells she
would say no man
john you go to the gummy candies when
you're not doing well when you're
stressed when you're anxious
right john you drink more than normal
wind fill on the blank
yeah and if i was dating somebody
who was
crushing it
and trying to give me dietary tips
and trying to
ask me why i wasn't using the expensive
gym membership they bought me i'd drink
more too dude
so i've just been i've been approaching
it completely wrong
um
is that is that kind of where you're
getting that i'm getting at this
start treating her like she is a person
to be with and a person to love and not
a puzzle to solve
she is not a
malfunctioning
chevy engine that just needs to get the
uh you know
you know new headers or
you know new spark plugs yeah sir yes
sir i understand she's dealing with
something in her heart or she's not
or she's not she may think she's
beautiful and that things are great
and she gets to do that
yeah she does it is beautiful it sounds
like she's told you she doesn't like the
trajectory of
where she's headed that she doesn't like
feeling unhealthy that she doesn't like
um the decisions she's making which
tells me she's got underlying things and
again don't hear this everybody
listening and say because she put on
weight so you're such a jerk now that's
what i'm saying i'm saying if somebody
is
saying whatever the behavior is i'm out
of control and i can't stop
i've had several of these declarations
in my adult life about my addiction to
sugar i got a problem dude like a bad
problem
and there's been several times that i've
reached out to friends or to my wife and
said i can't stop i have to not have
sugar in the house for about a month and
i gotta give away my debit card
and my wife says cool i got you
and her and my kids will go to sonic
without me right they'll sneak and go
while i'm at work right
um
but that's not about food that's about
something totally different
but i've also had seasons where i'm like
brother it is dissertation time i'm
writing a book time i'm just gonna eat
i'm gonna enjoy my life i know i'm gonna
pay for it later but i'm gonna have fun
with it right and those are two totally
different mindsets and so if she's not
loving the way she looks and she is
heartbroken
i want you to ask her where the
heartbreak comes from i want you to hold
her hands and say i'm not going to give
you any more advice
i'm just going to give you a safe place
to share
or if she says
i'm really struggling with
drinking too much then man that's not a
weight issue brother there's something
else going on
yeah
she may be really nervous because she
knows you're about to ask her to marry
her
yeah she may be really nervous because
she is not totally sure about your
relationship or she may just be really
nervous because 2020 sucks
yeah it sure does and she's in the
middle of a pandemic and and work and
whatever and whatever in a partridge in
a pear tree all that to say is this
i can hear in your heart that you love
this girl
and i can hear in your voice
that you are doing the best things that
you know how and so on behalf of every
guy across the country i want to honor
you trying to love her the best you can
i also want to tell you that it's not
working
yeah and so i'm going to ask you on
behalf of every guy in america stop
okay okay
from this point forward
i want you to ask permission to give
advice
when she tells you something i want you
to say are you asking for my input here
or you just want me to hear you
okay and she may fall over dead she may
absolutely pass out from that new
stephen right
yeah for sure um and i don't want you to
beat yourself up over shallowness and
superficiality right
50 pound weight gain in a year says
something's going on
yes sir okay something's going on right
whether it's physiological it's
biological it's psychological
something's going on there right
and that's not something that fish and
chicken's gonna solve
okay well i appreciate all the input
you've given me well i appreciate you
being a guy that's
i'll tell you this when you're first
rattling this stuff off i thought you
were setting me up and you're gonna get
me fired
and i was just gonna say mean things to
you after hearing you i actually
i really believe that your heart's in
the right place and you're really trying
to do the best you can
and this is just a hard season for
everybody
i would strongly recommend that you and
your wife go see a premarital counselor
if that's the road you're taking
and you don't have to get engaged to do
that you could say hey i see us spending
some time together in the future i want
to learn ways that i can support and
love you better
and i'm a knucklehead
i love my gym time i love
finding new discipline quotes from jocko
i love finding new keto diet recipes
beefcake2000
right
but she doesn't and you want to learn
new ways to communicate with her and
support her and love her better to give
her a safe place
a peaceful place
and if at the end of the day she chooses
man i just have no interest in
the the physical health stuff that
you're interested in i like to eat i
like my body i think i'm beautiful
then you have a choice to make
but i want you to start with listening
start with loving start with leaning
into the relationship part not to the
fish and chicken fix here's a uh
a
new program and by the way dude
when you invest money in somebody you
love and it doesn't work out don't hold
them
hostage with it
she wanted to go to a really nice gym
she thought that's what it was going to
be
and
then you did a cool thing a noble thing
you sprung for expensive gym and then
she probably walked in there and saw all
those super fit people and all their
super fancy million dollar workout
clothes and she
said nope i'm not going
and i know too many women who've had
that exact experience i know dudes who
have that experience
so it is what it is it's a sunk cost you
learned
don't beat yourself up don't beat her up
over it it's expensive yeah
chalk it up man if she's the girl for
you over the next 50 or 60 years you'll
have plenty of those moments and she's
gonna buy you something fancy and she's
gonna miss the mark on that too just
part of it right
hold on studio
she gained weight what do we do
yeah we need like a live uh roaming mic
for them to give commentaries absolutely
we do not we don't it'd be a dreadful
idea i love that uh i love the term
happy weight they gain happy weight yeah
i mean like i said we were all like oh
man delaney's going to smash this guy oh
obviously
yeah it was like a rocky it was like a
montage scene before this and you saw it
coming and when you said
i kind of want to light you on fire
right now that was that was my favorite
okay i need to stop there right there so
we listen i listened to a couple of
these last night and
so i'm a year removed from a lot of
these i haven't listened to these stuff
i don't ever ever go back and watch
these things again
dude i've got to apologize to the
listener and i'm being serious about
this
i have so many references to i would hit
that dude in the mouth i would like this
on fire
i'm probably the least violent guy i
know
and
that those are i went i checked out some
of the youtube comments again because i
was you know i was like you know i
haven't been sad in a long time i'm just
going to uh jump swan dive into the
sadness pool
but a lot of them were right and uh i
remember somebody made a really crass
disparaging remark about somebody's
special needs and
i told um
a wife to hit her husband like
i guess hey
that's me trying to like shock value
and it's not good like
i wouldn't hit anybody like that's such
such a stupid useless way i trade mma
free like i know i like fighting and it
never solves anything so i just don't
i've banished it from my life and i've
got to stop making those type of
analogies here because i don't want
someone to hear that and be like well
you know what i should i should right
it's stupid i think people take it as
hyperbole and it but it shows that
you're fired up but i get it but when i
went back and listened to it it sounded
like i was
being a bravado idiot you know what i
mean i don't know i'ma quit doing that
i'll put that in the money jar for kelly
yeah i'll count on that yeah just
start yeah i'll go ahead and get your
your amazon account set up we'll get you
paid you're gonna pay for my son's
college before this is all said and done
yeah that's right that's right we're
gonna get a time zone jar and a swear
jar and a listen jars and a violence jar
it's gonna be great excellent so okay um
so yeah i wanted to hate this dude and
then halfway through i realized oh no
he's a really good human being he's
trying to love her the best he can he
didn't have the tools in his toolkit and
then as we started talking about him he
was all about what because he even said
oh no i've been doing this all wrong
and he thought just encouraging her to
get on her exercise bike or eat fish and
chicken or
when she's crying be like well why don't
you just get a good workout it right
whatever and to hear to tell him dude
what are you doing and him to go oh no
you could hear it on him that he was
such a lovely human who's just doing it
sideways
yeah i will say um when i had to call
this guy and schedule this call it was
one of those you know i don't i don't
hold my tongue well
we all know and
alert i know but when i had to call this
guy
and schedule it and i was just like what
would you like to be on because i was
thinking i hate this person he's shaming
this woman so i probably i apologize to
him if he's out there wasn't as friendly
as i should have been because i had the
same thing i was like we're going to get
this jerk on the radio and then just
bash him and then by the time it was
over i was like oh well there's a lesson
learned for me but also because he
really was doing it from such a good
place he wanted her to be healthy he
knew she was unhappy and that's such i
mean that's like the whole you know do i
look honey do i look fat you know never
answer that dude don't answer that yeah
and but he just wanted what was best for
her and he was he was going about it the
wrong way and you know but
how was he to know so this comes back to
i think one of the most important
lessons i've learned over the past year
is
what looks like something on the front
is almost never what it looks like and
it's always worth sitting down and
asking somebody tell me some more about
that
instead of just swinging at them and man
we've gotten good with our little
cellular devices and our instagrams and
whatevers of just beating each other up
on face value without asking some deeper
questions
and this guy's a perfect example like he
was watching somebody he loved in pain
and frustrated and
he wasn't as attracted to his i mean all
that stuff was true
and i think he's allowed to say that out
loud and i don't think so i i know he is
it's how you do it and with the heart
behind it and the attention and and and
but yeah um it was another both hand
thing it's like you're allowed like you
made the point if i came home 50 pounds
heavier it would be a thing
like that
it seems like kind of in today's world
you're not allowed like you can't say
that out loud but it's like no
you need to go about it the right way
and have the right motive and
she needs you know she needs help and
clearly there's something else going on
so that's cool why don't we talk about
weight especially when we have to if you
look at the the obesity trends if you
look at the metabolic disease stuff it's
unfathomable
the numbers
why can't we talk about weight
well especially right now it's such a
taboo thing why
it's supposed to be acceptance
but there's a difference between
acceptance and
i hate to say like endorsement of you
know yes you still love people
regardless but there's a health issue as
well yeah but yeah it's such a
taboo topic that you're not supposed to
comment on or even like notice yeah well
and just the attraction the health of
how you sleep to how you feel all those
things have just become so third rail
that everyone's supposed to just shut up
and ignore each other and
i don't know i
i think yeah it comes back to a heart
issue and you're sitting down and saying
are you okay are you all right and being
honest all the way around 360. i don't
know what do y'all think
you can't even answer don't answer guys
don't
i love it you'll make me so happy all
right what's next which one's next so
the next one was also
a one of our most popular ones but it it
was to me it's kind of the
the other end of this yes yes so the
title of this one is boyfriend thinks
i'm lazy and out of shape
uh this was episode 107 from back in may
and this one
um i got pretty fired up on this one
yeah this is one where there was not a
uh
there wasn't so much a actually he has a
point it's like this guy is just
straight up jerk so and it got even it
started off kind of like man can you
believe this and then it got just really
sad yeah so we'll watch this one and
then comment all right boyfriend thinks
i'm lazy and out of shape from episode
107 from may 7th 2020 here it is so my
boyfriend and i have been together for
six years and we have two babies
together we have a step we have a seven
month old and a two-year-old
so you're in it now huh
yeah a minute do you even hey do you
even know what day it is
i i actually don't i know it's somewhere
in april
i love that okay
um all right so
you have a two-year-old and a seven
month old you don't know what day it is
and i can only guess where this is going
you've been dating this guy for six
years
yeah and then what
well
so he kind of so we live together you
know we we play house as dave calls it
okay and
he has a hard time with me
well i guess i should say i have a hard
time keeping up with
his kind of
expectations
um so he wants me to exercise more and
to get my body back to the way it was
um but i feel so overwhelmed
but hey just uh just a quick thing does
he know that you have a seven month old
and a two-year-old i think he's picked
that up by now i think i think he might
pick that up myself okay
so i i i'm
trying to wrap my head around this
walk me through how that actual
conversation takes place
so he sees you breastfeeding a kid and
there's a two-year-old just screaming
and you
have dinner cooking and he looks at you
and goes
yeah this body is not cutting it you're
gonna have to fix it like how does that
even happen
he'll get home from work and he'll be
like so did you do your exercise bike
today gosh what
i say no i did not do my exercise bike
today
now
dr john i'm dealing with a guy who has
the mindset of jocko
i know but listen i do too i love jocko
i'm gonna do a speaking engagement with
him in a few weeks i love him and you
know what i don't never ever did looked
at my wife without holding a seven month
old and be like so how'd your workout go
today babe you know never you know why
because i have a soul
and i actually care about human beings
right that like i don't care jocko
wouldn't do that to his own wife and
he's got multiple he's got four or five
kids right
god almighty so
i always want to try to find the soul in
somebody what they're trying to trying
to be helpful
is
and my body's not even that bad i've
lost 70 pounds oh listen nikki this has
nothing to do with your body i'm trying
to get to a place where i can empathize
with this guy before i just hang up on
you and i call him directly so
that's that's not even our main problem
though oh sweet we'll continue nikki go
ahead uh so he's
he thinks i don't keep the house clean
enough oh gosh nikki listen and tour
toward the point he wants to kick me out
hey listen go ba
take both of those kids and go
i know i can't do that though hey listen
go
this guy's not worthy of another second
of your love and your time and your
affection
did i try
i try but it's just so much in a day he
says i spend too much time on
social media like i get that but i just
i don't have the motivation right now to
do any of anything
yeah no
have you left before
yeah i i just came back like a week ago
or yeah about a week ago
so you moved out okay so how was that
time away
it was very good um
it's hard you know living somewhere else
yeah why'd you come back two little
monsters
um well i just i want i miss him and
i
want my kids to be around their dad
hey i don't want my kids around a guy
like that
i don't want my kids around a guy like
that
i don't want myself
i don't want my friend nikki around a
guy like that
now here's the thing
he may understand
that exercise
especially for folks with postpartum
is really good for you
he may understand that scrolling social
media
is not good for you
right and he's right on both of those
things
but he also needs to know that beating
up on
a struggling mom of two tiny little
babies
clear there's other things going on in
your relationship
clearly and if he is somebody who has
chosen not to commit to you after six
years and two kids together and now he's
putting ultimatums on you because he
wants his old life back
and it's your job to get that old life
back for him then he's not somebody
that's going to be there long term for
you
okay
do you hear them you hear what i'm
saying
yeah you know i'm right aren't i
you are right yeah and i know my mind is
like you know if he's not willing to
marry me you know and not be like well
maybe if you because he says this is
like this is the job interview and if i
want the reason why wait wait
six years and two kids and you're
interviewing
yeah i know
nikki
you know who wouldn't put up with that
crap jocko
and i won't either
you're worth more than that
are you struggling right now yes
is exercise
i tell them it's just a season we're in
the thick of this so we're in the thick
of this right now and he's just it's
like it's in one ear not the other
doesn't care just it's like the only
thing he sees is the house
and the house is a little messy we've
got dishes and we've got dirty laundry
and there's toys everywhere and that's
all he sees i swear that's all he sees
and so one of jocko's core tenants is
when you see a challenge fix it
yeah and what every husband who's got a
wife with
a two-year-old and a seven month old in
the house should do
is step up and help with the dishes
for crying out loud and the vacuuming
and the laundry and i don't care how
many jobs you're working i don't care
how busy you are how tired you are
as you mentioned you're in a season
when it's winter everybody puts on a
jacket
everybody has to de-ice the driveway
everybody has to do different things in
winter because it's winter
and when you have a two-year-old and a
seven month old
everything feels a little bit heavy is
that right
oh yeah okay
and now listen
i will tell you in a more gentle way
you will never go wrong putting those
kids in a double stroller and going for
a long walk ever
you will never go wrong by being on your
phone less
right
and you know that right
oh yeah you'll never go wrong by by um
making a list of the things that you
need to do in a day
and
really leaning into them to use jocko
language to crush those things on that
list however big or small they are and
sometimes they're a small
for a mom with a seven month old and a
two-year-old sometimes it's as small as
i'm going to make the bed i'm going to
take a shower
and i'm going to fill in the blank i'm
going to do one thing around here
right
and you're going to sit down with him
and you're going to plan that out and i
would recommend doing it to the day
but if he said the words to you this is
a job interview i want
i want you to walk out the job interview
because you don't want to work there
you know what i mean you don't want to
work there and that is scary and that is
terrifying and that is
frustrating
that god does not deserve you
okay
you don't deserve to be interviewing
after six years in
kids i i i i completely agree okay so
what's stopping you what what's stopping
you
i don't want a broken family
it is broken
[Laughter]
it is
you running around with duct tape
doesn't make your tile floor not cracked
yeah
and what's happening is these these two
little kids are obs are figuring out wow
this is how this is how
parents act
this is how two people who play house
and love each other act does ellie treat
each other yeah
yeah
you know what i mean
i i get it i i get it
this is how a grown man
treats the wife of his two little babies
you know
yeah and that's that's what i'm afraid
of
don't be afraid of it because when you
say i'm afraid of it that's like saying
a bear might come this has come it is at
your door it is in your home
okay oh my gosh
i know i know so when when he when you
were off at your dad's house
was he calling you saying hey come home
come home i'm sorry
he
well let's let's
let's make note that there was not any
i'm sorry
thrown into this at all okay um
he
said he wanted to
but he didn't want to seem
desperate
i'm like what we're not date like we're
not like at the beginning of our
relationship you don't have to play it
cool i i can't date a robot anymore i
need to know like feelings i need to
hear these
these feelings i don't want to be
desperate
i know
i don't want to seem desperate and i was
like what do you mean desperate like if
your wife and your two babies leave your
house
that is the definition of desperate
and it was so funny i got it oh god it
was so funny he called me because he was
like hey the lights are out how do you
pay the electric bill
your lights got cut off
no
we did i didn't pay it in time and so
he's like hey could you pay this for me
i mean using his card and stuff and he
pays for it but he didn't know how to so
like i think that's a little desperate
honey okay so here's the deal nikki
here's what i want you to do in all
seriousness
and i know that you are laughing to keep
this
overwhelming tide of grief to come over
you is that fair
yeah definitely okay
so i want you
to
today call a
local counselor in your area
and set up an appointment for just you
okay okay spend whatever you got to
spend for child care call whoever you
got a call
um if you got to drop them off at your
dad's house drop them off your dad's
house
but i want you to go see somebody
and i want you to lay out here's what's
happening
and if you want to try and save this
relies because they save your marriage
but it's not even one
um you have a daughter
i have two sons two sons okay
so one of your sons comes home
in 22 years 23 years 24 years
and says hey mom you know susan i've
been dating for six years
we're having a second kid and i told her
this is gonna be a great try out for her
to see if she's gonna be the one we're
sticking around
what would your response to that boy be
i'd be so mad at him that's right
that's right
yeah
yep okay and i want you to treat
yourself
with that same level of care i want you
to treat those babies that same level of
care my deepest wish is that your
husband goes what am i doing
or your boyfriend does goes what am i
doing and he snaps out of it
okay and maybe he's misreading jocko and
misreading the understanding of what
that guy talks about
but the root of what he talks about is
ownership
responsibility
accomplishing a mission
right not berating
a
exhausted frustrated
um
postpartum
mother of their two babies
okay into every guy out there listening
to this
stop
stop
you want your wife to get off social
media give her a place worthy of being
off social media for
you and a wife who's not so exhausted
all the time
pick up the crap around the house
sit down and have that conversation with
her and say how can i honor you today
and i know you're off making the money i
know you're off doing your work blob
feeling whatever cool
you know you're not doing dragging
around two little kids
my wife's been out of town for a few
days and i've had the kids at my house
coming into work is a blessing and a
gift in a safe safe quiet place
and it's been like three days
not day after day after day after year
after year nicki i'm so sorry this is
happening to you and i'm sorry to tell
you this
but you know
i'm not telling anything new right
right yeah
is your dad in your corner is your mom
in your corner
definitely okay
so i want you to lean on them but today
i want you to go make an appointment
with a counselor and start getting the
help and care that you need and either
come up with a
a
if then if now if not now then
conversation
with your boyfriend
a practice conversation or
an exit strategy
sooner rather than later
you are not on a job interview
you are not trying out for this guy's
love
you're better than that you got more
than that
husbands
create a home for your wives so they
don't want to be on social media they
want to be with you
create an environment where they've got
space
to go exercise and move their bodies
into walk because there's not 40 other
things that you've given them to do or
they feel obligated to do in this space
so they don't even have time to take
care of themselves
create a world where
your partner's got space
man
i i hate that for you nick i'm
heartbroken for you she's louise i don't
even know how to end this show man
um
no you know what you're gonna end this
with strength just like i told the
caller earlier you've got the pen now
there's appear at the end of that
sentence when he said i don't appear
desperate cool
you are desperate you're at the end of
your rope and now you've got a pin you
get to write what happens next
and i want you to write
i matter my kids matter i'm worthy of
being loved i'm worthy being in a
situation where i'm not trying out where
i am fully known and fully loved
and i'm going to start taking the next
step to get there it's a teeny tiny
frustrating
collapsing step but i'm going to get
there i'm going to take the next one i'm
going to lean on my dad i'm going to my
mom i'll lean on my counselor i'm going
to lean on my friends in my community
because this guy said he won't be there
not until i passed the tryout which is i
guess is six years and two kids
later
but you're gonna be a fierce
bad man pajama nicki and we're all
rooting for you let me know how that
conversation goes let me know how
connecting with that counselor goes
gentlemen be better
i'm saying this to myself i got to be
better too but we got to be better
we got gotta be better than that and if
we got friends in our lives that
talk that crap to their wives to their
girlfriends we gotta be willing to step
up and say no
absolutely not
absolutely not it's not funny it's not a
joke it's not good bro
nope be better than that
we got to hold ourselves accountable
gentlemen
starting yesterday
what do you think kelly
winner winner chicken dinner huh i have
thoughts on this one what are you what
are your thoughts kelly i mean
i just was flabbergasted
this what does that word even mean
just kidding astounded that was a big
word yes that
here she was with a seven month old and
a two-year-old
and then he wants to know she got on the
exercise bike today
and my thought was
dude you do it you do her job and then
work out and then make sure the house is
clean i just don't think he had any clue
how exhausting what she was doing was
and
that's taking that's assuming there's no
postpartum issues
you know that she didn't have a
c-section that everything went great she
feels fine
all of that aside i just wanted to just
tell him to shut up and tell her to run
yeah and
then that then you even get to the whole
this is a tryout thing
yeah
i very very rarely do i ever hear on
this show you say you got it you got to
go you got to go yeah because by all you
know at all costs we want families to to
stay together
but this guy would have to do so much
work and if he was willing to do it
great
but i have my doubts so there's there
was a part of me that
again wanted to give him the benefit of
the doubt which was he knows exercise
important and he knows that
yeah i mean we we've all had friends in
our lives who are just scrolling
mindlessly you want to tell them hey
you're on the phone too much right
um
to me the the one that pushed me over
the edge and said oh this is not that
this isn't a guy who's trying his best
and just doesn't have the right words
it was a from a level of superiority
look at how i'm doing it and you need to
do it differently and then
just imagine you're holding a
five-month-old in one arm and you got an
18-month old and the other arm and he
sits you down and looks at you in the
eyes
says honey i got an announcement for you
and she's like what is that i'm just
picturing her all tired like
hair is there like what what um what
what's the announcement
you are officially in the running now to
be my wife
and having her be like oh
hooray
hooray i'm so excited um what do i need
to do
and then being like two big ones
clean my house and get that body back
and then we're gonna talk about i just
can't wrap my head around that
it kept getting worse and worse because
first it was body back and that was like
keep the house clean and then it was
your trying out and then when she
finally left him
he said well i want you back but i don't
want to see him desperate yeah i can't
say i'm sorry for being like i don't
want to seem like i'm yeah and then he's
like uh hey while i have you on the
phone um how do i pay the electricity
bill
okay so the big question is how do you
get so far down the road
because that question when i asked her
how would you treat
what would you say to your son if he
came and told you this and she just
started crying
how do you not be able to see in the
mirror
i have an answer to that i'm just asking
you guys what do you think
well i answer you know of course from a
female perspective of we're taught to
try harder
do more
and so she probably thought okay as long
as i do this thing or do this thing or
wear this or
and that gets and then you just get in
that wheel
of it and then on top of that
i mean
i say mommy brain but parent brain she's
probably not sleeping
and you're just trying to she's in
survival mode not
and unable to step outside at that point
and go this guy sucks i need to get out
of this you're just trying to make it
work you're trying to get through the
day with everybody alive the house is
not burned down everybody got fed and
hallelujah that's a good day
and then
and then trying to keep a family
together as well because you don't want
to be the one that says that broke up
the family yeah
and when someone's telling you if you
don't do this it's going to be because
of you
the temptation is to try to solve that
so i read a book a few weekends ago
it's called chatter i think the author
is crop k-r-o-p-p we'll have to check on
that
um
but there was some really fascinating
research that was neat in this and it's
changed even in the last couple of weeks
how i approached some of these problems
said that there is and i hate to use
technology analogies you all know that
but
said the wiring system when you are say
i when i'm in it
it that is the one that triggers fight
or flight that one's the one that says i
me am not safe or i me am okay there's a
reason why when we're struggling with
our marriages or with our friends or
what do you do with my kids
we're like i don't know
it feels like we're having to make all
these decisions and then somebody that
you work with comes up to you and says
hey what do i do about this and you go
oh do these three things that your
brain's got a different circuitry for
handling over their issues or them
issues and so hearing her
stumble through i don't know what to do
with my situation but be able to answer
her sons right away was boom so clear
two different circuits man she could see
his so clearly and so there's something
about distancing yourself from your
current situation and just asking
um some of the stuff he asks or he that
the author suggests is to when you write
your journal write to yourself don't
write like i'm really struggling with
this right james is really having some
concerns answering these questions or
kelly is right to yourself in the third
person and it allows some space between
the issues that you're working through
and the solutions are so much
clearer and they come so much quicker
when you're right in the middle of it so
if she is to write herself a letter
saying dear so and so
you have two kids by this guy and now
you're auditioning you would i mean you
just laugh out loud be like oh well then
i'm out of here right you would just do
that right away but when you're in it
man it just feels like you're in it
because you're every hormone
and blood-saving not blood-saving
chemical but adrenaline of course all so
you know that stuff just to say and
survive survive survive and suddenly you
find yourself waited out way past where
you should be swimming yeah and when you
pointed out you know she didn't want to
have a broken family you're like look at
this situation this is broken this is
broken as it gets yeah and you can just
hear her exhale like oh man we're in it
we need to follow up with her too
yeah i'd love to follow up with her um i
think we're gonna plan that for the
coming weeks is we'll have a follow-up
show and get some of these folks back on
and it's so awesome if they're like you
sucked alone we did everything you said
and this is the worst you're the worst
pretty awesome i wouldn't talk to my
therapist and they said you're a [ __ ]
that'd be great
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
we have one more yeah one more what is
it you got it
where is it oh
yeah
the last one here
i get annoyed by my wife's feelings sent
in by james child james so what were you
thinking about this when you sent it in
this guy was from louisville
so ridiculous
louisville is how it's spelled the wool
is how it's pronounced
so ridiculous
um you guys out there do you all get uh
you men and women
powerful brilliant men and women do
y'all get annoyed by your
partner's feelings
just take a dive man
rachel's like
everybody froze
don't move don't move don't move that
was awesome except for rachel she's like
yeah for sure good job
we'll let him know it's good
that's awesome
all right all right so here we go the
last one i get annoyed by my wife's
feelings
matt
hey why before we get going is it
louisville or louisville
it's louisville
louisville i'm from texas no when
somebody's not from the area because
they say lewisville or louisville i'm
from texas and tennessee i'm going with
louisville man
all right that's something matt from
woolvolt go ahead brother
yeah um so i'm calling in because
my wife and i we've been married almost
10 years in this october this coming up
october
this is kind of before where she said
that i've just been a very selfish
person
a lot of times like she'll come and tell
me that i've made her upset about
something and my go-to emotion seems to
just be
anger
like
i just get mad at her
or
telling me that i messed up with
something and
that i didn't fix something the right
way and like i guess
i kind of get scared like when she
brings that to me
because i feel like i'm supposed to fix
her problems even if it's not a problem
between us it's just an emotion that
she's had with someone else and she's
coming to me
because i'm her husband i'm supposed to
be there to listen to her
and
i just
i don't know why but my go-to emotion is
anchored you just jumped issues on me so
she you
you made it sound like one thing but
it's actually two
so she comes to you with challenges
about you first
and you respond with anger
and then
separately so there's a period at the
end of that sentence then separately she
comes and talks about other feelings
she's having
about other issues she's having other
people and that makes you angry and
frustrated too because you know how to
solve those
right yeah okay so let's deal with the
first one when she comes to you and says
she's got problems with you or she
doesn't like the way you've done
something is she right
90 of the time yeah so why do you get
angry
i guess because i try to be i'm a
perfectionist i try to make everything
perfect and
when something doesn't go
the way i thought it should go
it angers me
and if i'm if i'm doing something and i
thought i did it correctly and it was
great but it upset her and then she
comes and tells me about it
that i think that's where the anger
comes from and i thought well in my head
it was perfect
and it was great but are you angry at
her are you angry at you
i think ultimately i'm angry at myself
but i take it out on her
[Music]
and maybe i am angry at her too for a
little bit because she pointed it out
but i know that's how i grow and i
make improvements to myself when people
point those
criticisms out to me
yeah so dude here's the thing um dr chip
dodd i love the way he presents anger uh
he helped me reimagine anger all anger
is
is a cue that you care about something
it's a good thing
it is a
directional arrow towards something that
you are passionate about that you love
or that you care about
that's what anger is right okay acting
immature and acting like a six-year-old
and stomping your feet and yelling or
lashing out to somebody at somebody
who's trying to help you
is
um like i said that's acting like a baby
acting like a child
and so
feeling angry having that well up inside
of you i tried my best and it wasn't
good enough or i tried my best and i
just did the wrong thing man that's
natural feeling that's good
treating your wife
with disrespect
treating her without dignity just
because she's trying to lean into you
man that's not cool at the end of the
day
you're letting your feelings and your
emotions drive your car instead of your
thoughts and your actions
okay and so the default setting you've
got to adjust to brother is think about
a car
the front two tires
those are your
thoughts your thinking and your actions
and so when she comes in and says hey
man you did the dishes last night you
put them all in the wrong spot we've
talked about this can you please put
them in the right spot
and the thought pops in your head oh
yeah well you
that's when you have a moment to stop
stop that thought and say nope
and then you can replace that thought
with you're right we've talked about
this and i was trying to do something
nice
um and i didn't do it right and i'm
gonna fix that and then your actions are
you can stand up and go fix it or you
can stand up and look around and say
thank you for telling me that i was an
idiot and let that be that but instead
you're letting the back two tires of
your car which is your physiology like
the way your body feels
your heart gets racing and your chest
gets tight and you flex your muscles and
you're like what's up
and your emotions right they rage you
just get angry angry right right and so
you have got to practice
moving your
letting the front two wheels of your car
drive brother and then the other side of
this man
when she comes to you with hey this
happened today this is a feeling i had
this is a frustration
why do you get angry about that when
she's trying to connect with you that
way
i don't know that's that's a really good
question and that's kind of like what
i'm trying to figure out is why
that upsets me i guess that's where like
my selfishness comes in
to where
i'm just like well that happened to you
that didn't happen to me but that sounds
like really bad when i hear it i've
never actually said that out loud and
that doesn't make me feel good
so i'm i'm laughing i'm laughing at you
not with you okay like
what
why would somebody that you're married
to for a decade of your life she's
basically another arm and leg for you
right
why does her thoughts and feelings annoy
you
i don't know
that's a good question where is that
selfishness rooted in man
i guess maybe that i feel like
i don't i don't really know i don't want
to say this
um
because she has i mean there's a couple
issues that we're trying to deal with we
actually just started marriage
counseling monday night right and so
we're kind of working through that
but um
i know when
something hasn't happened
that i need in our marriage
it
makes those times when she comes to me
with her feelings
and i'm i'm kind of like acting selfish
so i'm like well you didn't give me what
i need so i'm not going to give you what
you need
so are you talking about sex she doesn't
perform like you wanted to or with the
regular you want so you're going to show
her
right
and where does that
where does that behavior usually start
i'll just cut to the chase it starts on
a playground
right you didn't pick me for your team
so i'm not gonna pick you for my team
again we are back to
back to my brother matt in louisville
acting like a four-year-old the beauty
is i will say this you've done a very
um admirable adult thing and you have
decided you're gonna go work on this now
she may be dragging you but the deal is
you're going here's what i want you to
promise me and the entire world
listening to this podcast you got it
yep when you go to your next counseling
session
i want you to tell them i talked to some
yahoo
on the radio some quack on a podcast
and i said some things out loud that
made me realize i'm selfish and i'm
immature and i want to fix that
and my promise to you is there are ways
to fix that
you and your wife are in a
wonky dance right now
where
you have shut off all environmental
signals for intimacy and for connection
because she's coming to you with her
feelings she's coming to you with her
heart and you are getting frustrated and
annoyed by that because she's
interrupting your game or you're
checking out golf stuff on a website or
whatever weird stuff you do in
louisville and
you're frustrated and so she has no
environmental
um
signal saying that you want to be
connected you want to be intimate and
then you circle around and be like hey
i'm not getting enough sex
and so i'm going to show you
and there's nothing sexual about what's
going on in your house right now because
you're annoyed by her
um you're annoyed when she shares her
heart you're annoyed when
she doesn't do exactly what you want and
it's just making this figure eight of
frustration right and so at some point
somebody's got to step up and say i'm
breaking the figure eight i'm gonna stop
it
and sexuality and intimacy and
volume that starts with a series of of
environmental offs and ons not a series
of my sex drives more than yours that's
a whole other conversation that we can
have another day but i want you to start
with your therapist start with your
marriage counselor i'm proud of you for
going man
walk in that door and say hey listen i'm
selfish
i'm immature i act like a child
the way i respond to you leaves no
no room for you to even think about
intimacy in here because i've not
created a safe and welcoming place a
place where you belong where your
feelings belong where i can listen to
you where i can just look at you and say
that sucks
i hate that somebody treated you like
that at work today
or man i didn't do the dishes right
again oh my gosh i'm so sorry i'm gonna
get it right i walked right past my
shoes that i left on the front porch i
didn't fill your car up with gas
i'm sorry i'm gonna make that right and
not that little boy rage it's like oh
yeah well i'm taking my bag and going
home
that starts with you matt that starts
with you and i think you've got the
courage to do it
and i'm giving you a hard time because i
see some of that behavior in myself i
see that behavior in millions of men all
across the country
where we were not taught we were not
trained on how to be in relationship we
were taught how to win
we were taught how to compete and we
were taught that being a boy meant
being over not with
and i want you to
and take this time take this snapshot
you've been together a decade you got
decades ahead of you i want you to take
this time with a marriage counselor and
i want you to learn the skills of
connecting
okay we're back i don't even know what
to say after that
that was a that was an early episode
that was episode six yeah i didn't do a
good job on this call i talked too long
i tried to force an analogy with the
cars and the tires and
i i don't know i was trying to actually
kind of like the cars in the tires thing
that made sense to me that it's from an
old psychiatrist william glasser but you
got to set it up and it wasn't even my
analogy and so i ended up like oh i got
to go i tried to force it in there and
it just i felt like i talked too long on
that one this is another one where
there's something to be said for just
when you when you say
these things that you're thinking out
loud to another person
when he said
you know she
she comes home and tells me she had a
hard day and i'm just like real annoyed
because i'm like well that happened to
you not me and he's like wow i just
heard how that sounded just saying it
out loud people would just they don't
have to call they don't have to call
someone just speak your feelings out
loud and then you'd be like oh man now i
understand but that's another one of
those where he could have written
himself a letter saying
james you're really annoyed when your
wife comes home and says hey had a rough
day
and you'd go like what an honor that is
that she would bring that home to me not
that's your problem
um
it's another call with the challenges
around sex so so hard it felt like once
at the very end there we got to
we're not having enough sex and that is
his filter by which he is viewing the
status of this relationship and then
everything else
is a barrier to him getting what he
wants here
um it means so much so many different
things to so many different people and
again we have to be more open in our
relationships about
sex i just don't i can't wrap my head
around i'm sure there's some great
cultural studies or something on how it
just became so
in intertwined with our our identity and
an inability to have that conversation
with our
spouses we talk about everything else
except for that i don't know it's just a
strange universe we live in there what
do you think kelly
this isn't going to win me too many fans
um
we don't have a lot of fans so we're
going to the two um
i am not very girly in my
i need to talk about my feelings
at all
and so i i see where he comes from on
some of that where i get annoyed too and
i i can fall in that that's your issue
not mine because i'm just such a we'll
go fix it person just go that's stupid
go do it and so sometimes i don't have
to be like hey just listen
to how his day was and what all happened
and i'm sorry about that but that's not
i don't default to that of being able to
let me tell you all my feelings about my
day i'm always like it was fine i dealt
with it you know whatever
but i loved the part when you talked
about the uh the figure eight part
because that is something in different
issues but that my husband and i went to
counseling for for quite a while about i
do this because you do this but i do
this because you do this well one of us
has got to stop doing this thing that's
right or we're just going to do this
forever because it's so easy
to this is my stand
this is all i have
to punish you or to to whatever
but then it's just you know the
definition of insanity doing the same
thing over and over again
difficult yes and it's not gonna happen
until you just figure out yourself right
into the ground
and someone has to be the one to go you
know what then i'm going to stop doing
this thing
and do something different yes something
you talked about that earlier something
different has to be done anything
different and that's so if you're him
and you're thinking man
my
i'm not having the sex i want to be
having right now
i guess you can try to get angry and
annoyed and frustrated and you can make
that your life's mission
and then just step back and say and what
i do is what i'm doing working is it
getting me
and are we having more sex the answer is
clearly no and so
do anything different right do anything
different here's a great one try sitting
down and talking and saying i've been a
jerk and i'm a bit annoyed and i want to
try something new or just start doing
something new i don't know for crying
out loud i do want to point this out
though kelly you bring up a great point
we often use our romantic partners as
trash bins we dump all of our crap on
them and so we get home and they're the
person who gets all of i didn't feel
good today my back hurt my knees hurt
can you believe so-and-so did this at
work so instead of the work i used to be
so guilty of that
oddly
my wife would show up to events with us
and she would not like people and i
would say no they're great she's like i
don't like them because they always do
this this and this and i realized oh no
like
i give you five interactions out of a
thousand that i have with this person
because all i do is just bring home the
junk
and so i found two things number one me
bringing home the junk was i only had
one tool on how to connect so that's all
i knew
and so if you all you do is bring home
garbage to
your husband or wife your spouse stop
think of another way you can find good
things in your day to talk about
the second thing is
is
i don't even know how to say this
create some space whether it's we got 30
seconds to talk about work and then
we're done with it like because we're
not gonna bring i'm not gonna bring that
home all the time right so create a
boundary where i'm gonna tell you some
negative stuff that happened and then
we're gonna get out of this thing but
that again that comes up with
intentionality and deciding we're gonna
connect and it's not just gonna be about
crap yeah because we don't know the
she may just be following him around the
house for you know five hours tonight
and then this happened and then this
happened and then this happened and that
does get really wearing when that's all
you're talking about or it's you know
like you said
bad news all the time so sometimes you
do have to set aside those
okay we've got 10 minutes tell me what
happened
do you want me to fix it or do you want
me just to listen that's right that's a
big one
and then then we're done with it because
yeah i mean it it can get really
emotionally wearing i remember my mother
telling us when we got married don't
tell me about your fights with your
spouse mm-hmm it's because great wisdom
then
when i see them i think you hurt my
child i have to hate them on your behalf
so don't tell me that yes yeah you have
to go fix that or talk to your
girlfriends or whatever so maybe she
also needs other outlets
than just him you know girlfriends or
therapists or whatever here's my guess
in this relationship
she got the gap too she felt it
and he thought it was a sexual issue she
thought it was an intimacy connection
issue so she tried to solve it by
talking more
and being more open about how she felt
about things
and
they ended up being like the
the same size of a magnet right and they
just keep pushing each other away even
though trying so hard to connect man i
think this this is i mean very early on
episode number six
we saw like how big of a deal
intimacy is for
everyone but especially our audience
and it we just did an audience survey
recently and that was like the top
pain point for people's is struggling
with intimacy i know all the live events
you've done that's been a huge topic
that we we're starting to introduce it
at live events and even
you know as the show as our show
progressed you started asking even when
it seemed like it was left field you're
like hey how's your intimacy because
like you said it is a barometer
for so many things in the root of so
many things in relationships and
everything's
revolves you know at some level around
connection and intimacy so um
it's cool it's
this was a sad call but it's cool to
it's cool that we're starting to have
that conversation on the show and at
live events and stuff like that yeah and
i mean if five years from now
the millions of people who are listening
to this
have
learned some new tools
just for having conversations in their
house what a gift right
it'd be such a shift because then their
kids get to watch how you have those
conversations
and the whole tension in the house goes
down right and
um the kids get to go to school with a
little less tension in their hearts and
minds and man you talking about legacy
change there so well cool man that's top
five way to go everybody we made it a
year thanks everybody
stay in school don't do drugs thank you
all for all of your help in the gang
makes my heart feel good y'all are so
awesome thank you
and even z forward back there with the
with the internets on a cell phone it's
awesome
thanks everybody hey so james what do we
got coming up next
so we're going to be
trying out some new segments we've done
we've kind of just done this show where
it's been
you know we record for 45 minutes and
kind of do everything during the show
we're going to try to experiment with
shooting some stuff and putting it in
and some different types of segments
some fun stuff some more in-depth
teaching stuff so
um
yeah you guys stick around and hopefully
you'll like the new stuff we're trying
and if you don't we can always just
default to this lameness right that's
awesome kelly thank you
it's like one of the great honors of my
life i'm so glad you're in the gang
thank you it's been it's been a great
year
and james
i think the most important thing here i
wasn't gonna tell you good job that's
cool
james like signaled to me like you're
welcome brother but i wasn't gonna say
good job i was actually gonna say um you
and i have formed a pretty incredible
metal band
and seeing you week after week
just shredding on that gibson it's
actually cody's gibson
it's it's making my heart feel good
it's really brought us together
it has it's brought us together
if you're watching this show or
listening there is no golf too big that
you can't overcome it you can build
bridges
i don't know that sounded cheesy and
lame so you said you got the lyrics for
the day dude as we wrap up yeah kayla
and i got this one for the anniversary
okay yeah we got it so here we go
yeah
um this is in dedication to one year
anniversary of the show we went through
a couple different options and some of
them are a little bit creepy this one
feels more appropriate and i'm going to
try to read these lyrics with the same
amount of drama that you do on a normal
show
excellent bring them on all right
0-0
it must have been cold there in my
shadow
to never have sunlight on your face
you were content to let me shine that's
your way
you always walk to step behind
so i was the one with all the glory
while you were the one with all the
strength
a beautiful face without a name for so
long
a beautiful smile to hide the pain
did you ever know that you're my hero no
and everything i would like to be really
i can fly higher than an eagle
because you are the wind beneath my
wings
[Music]
i agree i agree i am to win beneath your
wings all right that's about enough of
that hey that's one year in thanks for
being with us we got 20 more years to go
or so right here on the dr john dolone
show